we complain and we have a complaining  culture but when you take responsibility  everything fundamentally makes sense to  you  because it's through the lens of your  creative power  right so you come into a reclamation of  the fact that you've always had  this world creating power and you've  been told you don't  and you need these authorities to help  you safely navigate the dangerous  random world you know that we live in  and the truth is that  when we shift out of helplessness and  dependency and into  self-possession all sorts of so-called  miracles  happen i believe that victimhood and  victim consciousness  is the only human pathology and once we  learn to transform that and step into  really in adult consciousness  which is far more complex and nuanced  and far more empowering  then we break free of so much  conditioning i mean nearly  instantaneously